now to our other top story a huge
foreign policy week for the Trump
administration the historic opening of
us and of the US Embassy in Jerusalem is
met with violent protests along Israel's
border with Gaza dozens of Palestinians
are dead and thousands more reportedly
injured the Trump administration is also
moving forward to try and denuclearize
North Korea earlier in Jerusalem the
president addressed the crowd with a
video message praising our country's
friend and ally Israel Israel is a
sovereign nation with the right like
every other sovereign nation to
determine its own capital yet for many
years we fail to acknowledge the obvious
the plain reality that Israel's capital
is Jerusalem the United States remains
fully committed to facilitating a
lasting peace agreement and we continue
to support the status quo at Jerusalem's
holy sites including at the Temple Mount
also known as Haram al-sharif
the White House says responsibility for
the violence quote rests squarely with
Hamas during the press briefing today
Raja was pressed on this check out this
surprising exchange with NBC's Peter
Alexander we believe that Hamas is
responsible for what's going on so
there's no responsibility on that on the
Israeli authorities kill at will what
I'm saying is that we believe that Hamas
as an organization is engaged in cynical
action that's leading to these deaths
all right Jason let me start with you on
which every part you want the
significance of the day or the meeting
of some of the media take on it in terms
of the protest kind of an asinine
innuendo that they're just murdering
innocent civilians because they want to
I thought it was pretty insulting and
he's better than that because he's a
pretty decent reporter so I don't have
much to say about that but I think
what's making Trump so successful is how
he became successful as a businessman
and he's translating it into how he's
been a politician he's a man of his word
and he's a man of action and that's why
he's racking up all these tangible
victories you know it's I think in 1995
the Congress passed this relocation act
for Jerusalem and it took three
presidents who
nothing and stood by now Ivanka and
Jared are in there today for the opening
and this is coinciding with the 70th
anniversary of the establishment of the
State of Israel so of course you're
gonna have a little clash and you're
gonna have some blow-ups at the border
and that's to be expected because
Jerusalem I believe is the third most
holy city for Islam and that'll blow
over and you'll get the peace process
back on track I think Jared's doing a
pretty nice job you're gonna have the
Kushner Accords and hopefully we can get
that done maybe another Nobel Peace
Prize that one can be envious of and I
think the president when he does these
things it's because he doesn't care
about offending the status quo I mean if
you look at what happened with him
defeating the Caliphate or them NATO
countries ponying up their fair share or
tearing up NAFTA or renegotiating NAFTA
these kind of things he doesn't really
care about the blowback and he also does
the obvious I mean Jerusalem is
obviously the capital of Israel and it's
obvious we need a border with Mexico
it's obvious China's stealing jobs it's
obvious that North Korea needs to be
dealt with and now he's doing that
through the maximum campaign to pressure
diplomatically militarily even through
Twitter he's brought them to the table
they're gonna end the Korean War there
now I think totally imploding their
underground nuclear testing facility
they're sealing off all the entrances
that's a huge step releasing the
hostages is a huge step so now you have
this summit and Singapore and it's it
looks positive we're gonna go in there
with clear and open eyes I think the
five should maybe go to Singapore and
broadcast it since it's so historico and
we could all make the trip you want to
talk about Venezuela while we're at it I
did I would take issue with it other
presidents did nothing I do think that
this president was able to say the
conventional wisdom that there was going
to be the mass protests and the and the
violence that we saw some of today but
that it's not the parade of Horrible's
that people anticipated Kimberly and it
is possible that the peace process could
get back on track there is a better path
for the Palestinians if they if they
did but I think the one that the other
thing that's changed is also you have
now other countries like Saudi telling
the Palestinians you need to get on
board with what's gonna happen here and
there should be if you want a two-state
solution step aboard absolutely I think
you make a very important point when you
look at this moment in American and
Israeli history in terms of how it
affects that area of the world it's been
completely fraught with problems for so
long and I think this was a really
powerful move forward in the right
direction President Trump had the moral
and political courage to be able to do
this it was a promise that he made to
the people and he fulfilled it and I
think that's important as well to be a
person of your word even as you relate
to diplomatic relations with other
countries that if you say you're going
to do something and you make a promise
you honor it I'm very happy that there
wasn't a tremendous amount of violence
as if people were worried about that
things would happen if this were to
occur I think it is definitely a step in
the right direction in terms of the
relationship not only with Israel with
the United States with the Saudis being
on board and now let's get the
Palestinians to the table as well why
not try this is a first step in the
right direction to be able to do that
one I mean there was some violence we do
have about 51 people have died and they
say thousands injured in addition and so
maybe we'll find out more in the coming
days but due to Hamas no they they were
shot and killed by Israelis but there
was Raley's were they defending
themselves I mean I think the mosque
does try to make sure that the media is
covering it in that way well you guys
are so one-sided I don't surprised you
don't fall off the earth because it
seems to me because we're not flattered
there's because it seems to me it's so
clear that we're in a situation where
Israel is on the other side literally of
a fence but these people you have 35,000
people so it's much bigger than any
Hamas and you try to link it to a
terrorist group this is an expression of
people who feel that they are being run
over and run out of land and property
that was once theirs and that there's no
longer hope for a two-state solution
that Yahoo has made it very clear and
President Trump it looks like by making
this highly provocative move
doesn't care that's that the United
States has a role here potentially as a
you know we love Israel but we were
going to be the the force that
negotiated some kind of peace that
brought finally some peace to the Middle
East instead we have obviously Israel
firing at Iran in Syria Syria up in
flames now we have unsettled situation
here between Israel and the Palestinians
so what have we done we no longer
seeking peace Netanyahu apparently can
do anything he wants the Palestinians
feel greatly aggrieved and Hamas now has
more martyrs and you have extremism
fueled at this moment I don't I'm like
incredulous that you see this is good
well I did have a good point all right
before I just gonna say that it is in
Israel's interest as well to try to calm
the violence it is in their interest to
make sure that the Palestinians can have
but there is some sort of a two-state
solution so that they could live side by
side in peace and President Trump also
said that he believes that the status
quo with access to the holy sites in
Jerusalem should remain so I don't think
it's as bad as one was saying well I
just want to step back and diagnose the
problem is exactly what this is which is
we begin on one side and we end on
another side this is a prison this
entire issue is a prison of two sides
either Israel has a right to exist or
Palestinians are victims of violence
there's nothing there's no other side
and the intensity of media coverage on
this issue is the exact opposite of the
level of understanding and interest of
the public the public is not as
interested in this issue as the media
makes it out to be and this is why we
don't have any middle Middle East
experts we have more Middle Earth
experts than Middle East experts and so
you know that when this is gonna happen
they're gonna create programming
potential with retaliation well you know
that if you if you send out these
balloons filled with bombs you're gonna
get it on camera people are gonna die
that's what happened you get 50 deaths
the question is does this display of
violence and the suffering that occurs
have any effect in a land where four
decades of violence has been happening
anyway clashes erupted after this
embassy clashes erupt every single day
every single day we are jaded and
confused about this area and so I
resisted this idea that this is the
two-sided thing the next solution in the
peace process has to admit that the
current way of dealing with this is
going nowhere
it's going nowhere there's like there's
always a as long as there's always gonna
be violence there's always gonna be
violence there's got to be another way
well now at least the question of
Jerusalem is now off the table yeah and
then just really quick not to minimize
the violence or loss of life would
happen today the prediction was that
this would be catastrophic and
widespread and create an incredible
amount of tumult inand already like
geopolitically strife area but I'm
saying this is I think ultimately a
positive step towards peace